Roger stone is arrested president Trump
decides whether to declare a national
emergency over the border and the FAA
shuts down LaGuardia I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show I gotta say
the writers for season five of Trump
it's getting a little bit muddled at
this point honestly like you know that
there were some there were some nice
storylines they all seem to be coming
together they're coming together kind of
quickly kind of like Avengers infinity
war and now they seem to be kind of
splitting apart again it's a little
chaotic the directions a little messy
I'm not sure I can follow all the action
but don't worry we will break it all
down for you and bring you the latest
first let me remind you they need coffee
to get through this stuff and that's why
you need black rifle coffee because
morning coffee is an American
institution that's why when it comes to
starting my day I reach for the most
American coffee on the market black
rifle coffee black rifle coffee gives a
portion of their sales to veterans and
first responder causes their roasts to
order they guarantee a fresh delicious
coffee with every single order and black
right these rifles Coffee Club makes
things super easy just pick your blend
in the amount you want and black rifle
chips your coffee direct to your door
every month hassle free wake up with
America's coffee that is black rifle
coffee Blissett visit black rifle coffee
calm slash been received fifteen percent
off your order that's black rifle coffee
calm / ban for 15% off again black rifle
coffee calm / man the coffee is great
sort of the folks who run the company I
mean these are folks who are not
politically correct they're not gonna
back down in the face of silliness black
rifle coffee dot-com / men go check them
out right now and receive 15% off your
order again that is black rifle coffee
calm / been black rifle coffee calm so I
spent for 15% off all right so the big
breaking news just moments before our
show began today is the Roger stone has
been arrested now you remember Roger
stone from such things as I have a giant
tattoo of Nixon on my back and also I
say weird stuff a lot he's mostly known
for being a he's mostly known for being
a political operative very friendly to
President Trump he has now been indicted
it went down like this
apparently CNN was on scene for his
arrest and people were wondering why
exactly CNN was there so there was a lot
of speculation there was a leak from
Team Muller to CNN that they should be
there with cameras when Roger stone was
arrested in reality that's not what
happened CNN reporters apparently
we're at the DC Courthouse they saw some
extra filings with the grand jury and
they decided to stake out Roger stones
house figuring that he was next on the
indictment list especially since Roger
stone himself had said he was next on
the in citement list so that's how we
have this fascinating tape of an entire
SWAT team going to Roger stones house
now now normally I'm not too critical of
law enforcement
because you know they do what they have
to do but I do wonder why it took an
entire SWAT team to take down a 1000
year old man with a back tattoo of Nixon
I'm just wondering was was that super
necessary did they think that he was
gonna be holed up snorting lines of
cocaine and then he was gonna pull out a
giant minigun and shout it then say
hello to my little friend like what did
they think was going to happen here
anyway here is what it sounded and
looked like when the FBI arrested Roger
stone this morning this morning the FBI
has arrested Roger stone the president's
political adviser exclusive footage
you're looking at right now from CNN as
the FBI arrives at Roger stones
residence in Fort Lauderdale Florida
okay that's an FBI open the door and now
they're about to say another warning FBI
warrant you can see Roger stone right
here a little bit behind that door and
yes you know standard operating
procedure for the FBI to show up heavily
armed and right here like this
okay standard operating procedure maybe
or they could have just called the Roger
stones lawyer and said we're coming to
arrest you but probably they thought
that he was gonna destroy documents if
he knew what he was gonna be arrested
the reason I say that is because they
also raided his Manhattan apartment on
117 Street so what is the incitement all
about people immediately are saying that
this is all about Russian a collusion
okay let's make clear there has still
not been a single arrest for criminal
activity related to Russia the actual
charges here the actual charges are
lying to the FBI as have been the
charges for everyone so the very short
story of the Muller investigation so far
you can read it one of two ways the very
short story of the mall investigation
one way is people in the FBI did not
like President Trump that have been
people like Lisa Paige and Peter struck
and they decided that they were going to
initiate an investigation into Trump
when he was a candidate and now they are
racking up a bunch of
charges because they got a bunch of
schlubs to lie to them and that's what
that's the entire story of the campaign
was initiated in bad faith and these
arrests are merely a consequence of when
you ask political people embarrassing
questions they tend to lie to the FBI
that's read number one read number two
is that the investigation was initiated
in good faith that the FBI saw a lot of
Trump associates who are talking with
the Russians they saw a lot of movement
between the two sides and they figured
something was going on so they launched
a counterintelligence investigation that
has now become a criminal investigation
because of all of the people who lied to
them so we sort of have to determine
whether this was a good-faith effort by
the FBI or a bad faith effort by the FBI
what has not been established at this
point is that President Trump was
involved in criminal activity with
Russia now again that's a different
thing than did President Trump and his
campaign collude with Russia
so collusion was never a legal term
there is no crime of collusion right my
producers and I collude on this show
every morning that does not mean that we
have committed a criminal act although
some might want to arrest us for it the
fact that Trump and that team Trump was
working with people who were go betweens
for WikiLeaks is not quite criminal
activity Eugene Volokh had a long column
about this in the Washington Post a
couple of years ago than what you
discussed whether it was in fact a
criminal activity to work with foreign
sources to reveal opposition research on
your political opponent obviously it's
not I mean Hillary Clinton took
opposition research on Donald Trump from
the Ukrainian government apparently
during the campaign political reported
that that was not criminal activity it
is not criminal activity to work with
people from foreign countries to reveal
information about your opponent now
could it still be collusion in sort of
the colloquial sense is it bad that the
Trump campaign was working with
WikiLeaks which is an evil Russian
cut-out organization in order to target
Hillary Clinton yeah that's bad that's
not a good thing from any moral point of
view you do not want to be colluding
with WikiLeaks one of the worst
organizations on the planet even if it
means taking down somebody like Hillary
Clinton now listen that battle was
litigated and fought during the 2016
campaign and so I'm really getting
something that's already been closed in
the middle of that campaign Donald Trump
was saying I love WikiLeaks oh this is
not a new issue it's not as though he
was hiding this at all
the real question becomes twofold one
did Trump order this sort of collusion
between the campaign
and the Russians and to is that a crime
because it's not a crime it's not
impeachable it could be politically
damaging Helen we'll get to that in just
a second first let's talk about exactly
what Roger stone was arrested for so the
indictment charges that were in or
around May 2016
the Democratic National Committee and
the Democratic Congressional Campaign
Committee became aware that their
computer systems had been compromised on
or about June 14th 2016 the DNC publicly
announced that it had been hacked by
Russian government actors from in or
around July 2016 through in or around
November 2016 an organization WikiLeaks
which had previously posted documents
stolen from other US persons entities
and the US government released tens of
thousands of documents stolen from the
DNC and the personal email account of
the chairman of Hillary's Klamp campaign
that been John Podesta on or about July
22nd 2016 WikiLeaks released documents
stolen from the DNC between on or about
October 7th 2016 and November 7th 2016
WikiLeaks released approximately 33
tranches of documents that had been
stolen from the personal email accounts
of the Clinton campaign chairman
totaling over 50,000 stolen documents so
this is all stuff that we know right
there just recapping the story for you
then hero along comes Roger stone so
what exactly did Rogers don't do
according to the indictment during the
summer of 2016
Stone spoke to senior Trump campaign
officials about organization one that's
WikiLeaks and information it might have
had that would be damaging to the
Clinton campaign stone was contacted by
senior Trump campaign officials to
inquire about future releases by
WikiLeaks so now it looks like stone was
sort of the go-between between WikiLeaks
and the Trump campaign again that's not
criminal activity but it does look like
what we would call colloquial collusion
that they were seeking and getting early
warning from WikiLeaks about the emails
that were about to be released by in or
around August 2016 stone was claiming
both publicly and privately to have
communicated with WikiLeaks right
because stone is as it turns out more
from he's more from veep than he is from
house of cards by in or around mid
August 2016 WikiLeaks made a public
statement denying direct communication
with stone because their Russian front
group who lies a lot they're after stone
said that his communication with
WikiLeaks had occurred through a person
Stone described as a mutual friend
go-between an intermedia
airing this later ends up being
presumably radio host Randy credit Co
stone also continued to communicate with
members of the Trump campaign about
WikiLeaks and its intended future
releases after the 2016 presidential
campaign the US House of Representatives
permanent Select Committee on
Intelligence the FBI and the Senate
Select Committee on Intelligence
announced investigations into the
interference and then stone took steps
to obstruct these investigations
according to the indictment they say
that he made multiple false statements
to the House committee about his
interactions regarding WikiLeaks and
denied possessing records containing
evidence of those interactions they say
that's false and they say that he
attempted to persuade a witness to lie
and withhold pertinent information from
the investigations so here are the other
relevant individuals when his person was
a political commentator who worked with
an online media publication during the
2016 US presidential campaign person one
spoke regularly with stone throughout
the campaign including about the release
of stolen documents by organization one
speculation is hot that this person is
steve Bannon who ended up becoming the
Trump campaign chairman person number
two was a radio host who had known stone
for more than a decade this presumably
is Randy Crenna Co so here is what stone
was doing cuz they have all the
documents now apparently stone sent an
email to person one presumably abandoned
this is what the media reporting but the
subject line get to WikiLeaks the body
of the message read get to Julian
Assange at equatorial Embassy in London
and get the pending WikiLeaks email they
deal with the foundation allegedly this
is July 2016
on or about the same day person one
forwarded stones email to an associate
who lives in the UK and was the
supporter of the Trump campaign on or
about July 31st 2016 stone emailed
person one with the subject line call me
Monday the body of the email read in
part that person's one associated in the
UK should see Julian Assange on or about
August 2nd 2016 person one again
presumably ban an emailed stone person
one wrote that he was currently in
Europe and plans returned in or around
mid-august person one stated in part
word his friends and embassy plans to
more dumps one shortly after I'm back
second in August impact plan to be very
damaging the phrase friends in embassy
referred to the head of organisation one
that would be Julian Assange person one
added in the same email time to let more
than the Clinton campaign chairman to be
exposed as in bed with the enemy if they
are not ready to
drop Hillary Rodham Clinton that appears
to be the game hackers are now about
would not be would not hurt to start
suggesting hrc old memory bad has stroke
neither he nor she well I expected much
of the next dump focus setting stage for
the foundation debacle so all of this
early information coming via all of this
I'm sorry person one is not banning I
should I should retract up it's not
banning this is another character we'll
get to Manon in just a second so still
we don't know who person one is person
one is the go-between between WikiLeaks
and Roger stone in a second I'm gonna
explain the rest of the of the
indictment here and again nothing in the
indictment specifically cites criminal
activity between Roger stone and the
Russian government we'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
how you can make your business not suck
like apparently all the Associates of
the Trump campaign suck at their job in
the campaign I'm talking of course about
zip recruiter hiring can be pretty
time-consuming you posted job to several
online job boards only to get tons of
the wrong resumes then you have to sort
through all of those resumes just to
find a few people with the right skills
and experience those job sites that
overwhelm you with the wrong resumes are
not smart that's why you need zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire unlike
other job site cipro cruder finds
qualified candidates for you they have
powerful matching technology scanning
thousands of resumes so identify people
with the right skills education and
experience and then actively invites
them to apply to your job so you get
qualified candidates fast it's no wonder
zip recruiter is rated number one by
employers in the United States we use it
here at se Lee Weyer and if I do a bad
job today somebody else may be filling
my seat thanks to zip recruiter this
rating number one by employers in the
United States comes from hiring sites on
trust pilot with over a thousand reviews
right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire if you love the show show your
support for the show and zip recruiter
by going through zip recruiter comm
slash a daily wired Dai ly WI re zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire zip
recruiter is indeed the smartest way to
hire ok so again to reiterate the
correction person one is not Steve Danon
we'll get to Steve and in a second so
Roger stone was coordinating with this
person one who was apparently passing
information from WikiLeaks starting in
early August 2016 after receiving the
August 2nd 2016 email from person one
stone made repeated statements about
information he claimed to have learned
from the head of WikiLeaks so
he spoke publicly about this over and
over and over again because if you are
colluding with an enemy of the United
States presumably what you want to do
this because publicly about it as
possible over and over and over to show
your cool that's exactly what Roger
stone said I'm telling you the best
paper beginning on or about August 19th
2016 stone exchanged written
communications including by text message
and email with person two about
organization once a person to is Randi
credit Co apparently and and WikiLeaks
and what the head of WikiLeaks planned
to do there's a lot of coordination over
all of this and then there and then the
indictment suggests that stone started
coordinating with members of the Trump
campaign and this is where we get into
the really dicey part for a campaign
Trump because if stone were just dealing
with WikiLeaks and then revealing it
publicly online not only is he a private
citizen but he's not even associated
with the campaign so there really is
nothing with regard to the Trump
campaign to worry about but then things
get a little bit dicey so stones started
making statements to members of the
Trump campaign and supporters of the
Trump campaign runner about October 3rd
2016 stone wrote to a supporter involved
with the Trump campaign spoke to my
friend in London last night the payload
is still coming also honor about August
October 3rd 2016 stone received an email
from a reporter who had connections to a
high-ranking Trump campaign official
that asked the head of WikiLeaks what's
he got hope it's good stone report it
responded in part it is I'd tell that
high-ranking Trump campaign official but
he doesn't call me back that
high-ranking Trump campaign official
that is apparently Steve Bannon honor
about October 4th 2016 the head of the
organization WikiLeaks held a press
conference but did not release any new
materials pertaining to the Clinton
campaign shortly afterward stone
receives an email from the high-ranking
Trump campaign official asking about the
status of future releases by WikiLeaks
stone answered that the head of
WikiLeaks had a serious security concern
but that the the organization WikiLeaks
would release a load going forward every
week so that presumably is Steve Bannon
so because because there'd already been
public information about that email with
the phrasal load every week going
forward so apparently Bannon and stone
were in communication band at that time
was the chairman of the Trump campaign
later that day on about October 4th 2016
this
were involved with the Trump campaign
ask stone via text message if he had
heard any more from London and stone
said yes want to get on a secure line
got whatsapp stone subsequently told the
reporter that the supporter that more
material would be released and that it
would be damaging to the Clinton
campaign okay so again none of this is
the criminal activity what he's being
incited for is lying about all of this
so he went in front of the House
Intelligence Committee and he said that
he had no documents that dealt with any
of these questions when he testified
before the House Intelligence Committee
in his opening statement he said the
hearings are largely based on a yet
unproven allegation that the Russian
state is responsible for the hacking of
the DNC and he said that members of the
committee had made certain assertions
which had to be rebutted including the
charge that I knew in advance about and
predicted the hacking of the Clinton
campaign Chairman's email and then I
advanced knowledge of the source or
actual content of the WikiLeaks
disclosures regarding Hillary Clinton
and now how does this relate to Trump
well we've already mentioned we've
already mentioned that there is a
problem here
with regard to Steve ban and C Bannon
was associated with the Trump campaign
who was the campaign chairman he served
in the White House as the as the chief
adviser to the president
okay all of that is a problem for Trump
but there is one particular phrase that
is a a bigger problem for Trump okay
this is from the report after the July
22nd 2016 release of stolen DNC emails
by WikiLeaks a senior Trump campaign
official was directed to contact stone
about any additional releases and what
other damaging information WikiLeaks had
regarding the Clinton campaign stone
thereafter told the Trump campaign about
future releases of damaging material by
WikiLeaks notice the language there a
senior Trump campaign official was
directed to contact stone so in other
words somebody very high up in the
campaign was told by someone presumably
higher up in the campaign wink wink nod
nod maybe Trump to contact Roger stone
now this is not a criminal problem for
the president saying to his people go
get Roger stone on the phone right now
that is not a criminal activity
even saying go get Roger stone on the
phone right now he may have information
about information that's gonna drop
that's not illegal either but it is a
political problem for the president and
it's going to continue to undermine his
claims that there is no collusion
between his campaign and Russia because
now we have two actual separate
questions one
is there impeachable criminal activity
here and to is did the Trump campaign
collude with WikiLeaks if in fact the
Trump campaign knew that they were
getting extra information from WikiLeaks
a Russian government front group and it
was being funneled via Roger stone into
the Trump campaign that is collusion
even if it's not criminal activity and
that's not good for Trump now how does
all this play out now here's how it
plays out politically Democrats suggest
that they were right all along that
Hillary Clinton never would have lost
except for Donald Trump colluding with
the Russians again the evidence of that
is scanty WikiLeaks was gonna release
this stuff anyway they didn't need
advice from Roger stone and when to
release it and it turns out that there's
no actual information in this indictment
suggesting that WikiLeaks was taking
advice from the Trump campaign rather it
seems WikiLeaks was giving advance
notice to the Trump campaign which
suggests that they would have been
dumping this material anyway so take
number one from the left is going to be
Hillary Clinton lost because of
WikiLeaks Trump colluded the Trump
colluded part may still be true we don't
know yet we just don't know if she lost
because of it is pretty dicey but if you
think that's not gonna be a turnout
boost for whomever runs against Trump in
2020 think again
hey the Democrats are firmly convinced
that the 2016 election was stolen from
them even though that is not true
they're firmly convinced that it was a
legitimate even though that is not true
they are firmly convinced that if they
all show up they're gonna win in 2020
which may very well be true okay so the
narrative on the right counter
countervailing Lee is going to be that
there's no criminal activity here that
this was all the way Trump that it was
originally started for no reason other
than animus about President Trump that
you get a bunch of people in a room with
the FBI and Congress and you ask them a
bunch of embarrassing questions in
politics and they are probably going to
lie to you and that if Muller had
launched an investigation or if the FBI
had launched an investigation into
Hillary and then actually interviewed
Hillary without her lawyer present like
Cheryl Mills and then asked Hillary a
bunch of embarrassing questions she
would have lied about things if they had
launched an investigation into fusion
GPS and the steel dossier and Hillary
Clinton attempting to gain information
via a foreign actor Christopher Steele
about Donald Trump and then funneled
that to law enforcement via fusion GPS
if she'd been asked about that maybe she
would have lied maybe members of fusion
GPS would've lied maybe members of the
Hillary campaign would have lied we
don't know because that investigate
never took place so the case on the part
of the right is going to be in an
investigation in which you ask people
embarrassing questions they tend to lie
if all you've got is that they lied to
you without any evidence of underlying
crime then this really is a witch-hunt
now here's the thing both cases are kind
of true right it is kind of true on the
part of people on the right that if a
similar investigation had been launched
in depth against Hillary Clinton a bunch
of people would have gone to jail and it
is similarly true according to people on
the right if there is no underlying
crime as of yet I'm a part of the left
it is true that this is just more and
this is more evidence that members of
the Trump campaign were warm toward
collusion with Russia so all these
things can be true and it's all gonna
play out politically I don't think this
results in impeachment if all that ends
up happening here is more of the same
just more information on members of
Trump campaign lying about things that
are embarrassing all that's gonna happen
is everybody is going to be ensconced in
their own particular political position
and doubling down none of it is good for
a president Trump of course none of it
is good for 2020 but it doesn't actually
result in impeachment it does result in
more polarization and hunkering down
into our various bunkers okay I'm gonna
bring you the latest on the government
shutdown in just a second first let's
talk about your second Amendment right
so our founders knew that we had natural
rights given to us by God but that in
order to protect those natural rights we
had to sometimes engage our natural
rights to self-defense that's why the
u.s. CCA is there what if I told you
when you walk to the mailbox today you
will find the $1,000 you've been needing
to finally buy the gun of your dreams
you could add a Kimber a new hunting
rifle well that dream will come true for
10 of my listeners thanks to my good
friends over at the US ECA who provide
education training and trusted legal
protection for responsible gun owners
like you and me but if you want and you
have to hurry the US ECA wants to give
you ten free chances to win the gun of
your dreams entry is easy quick and free
but it's almost over and it all ends
next week just text win two eight seven
two two two two locking your entries
this is indeed your last chance if you
win you get $1,000 to buy the brand-new
gun of your dreams and remember it's not
just one gun you get ten chances to win
not only is the US ECA on a mission to
make sure every responsible gun owner is
educated trained and protected they just
love giving away guns but you're running
out of time don't miss your last shot at
getting the gun that you want next win
two eight seven two two two right now to
get you
for entries really there's no reason not
so you SCC is a great organization text
the word win two eight seven two two two
again win two eight seven two two two
all right so the latest on the
government shutdown is that things are
beginning to get incredibly ugly there
is an attempt yesterday by some
Republicans to fund certain areas of the
government or at least get people that
are paychecks right this isn't even
about funding of the government the
government has not run out of money it's
just that the payroll operating services
are not operating so Republicans
basically said okay well you know the
government shutdown can continue in that
we will not fund the government that
will not be a new continuing resolution
to fund the government but people should
still get their paychecks in particular
areas of the of the armed services
particularly yesterday senator Ted Cruz
got up and he said listen let's just
fund the Coast Guard I mean for goodness
sake let's get those guys their checks
every Republican agrees pay the Coast
Guard right now senator kennedy's bill
did one thing and one thing only it paid
the salaries of the men and women of the
Coast Guard it didn't touch any other
issue every Republican agrees with that
bill and the Democrats objected and said
we will not pay the go Coast Guard the
Republicans are willing to compromise
have offered to compromise and in fact
just now sought to pay the Coast Guard
and the Democratic position is no no no
we object and that of course is true
Democrats are not interested in
reopening the government at this point
they think that they actually have
stumbled upon a baton that Trump handed
to them and there's pretty good evidence
of that by polling data it is also true
that as the shutdown gets uglier people
are gonna get angrier and angrier over
it and they're gonna ask why doesn't one
side or the other just cave now again if
President Trump had spent the last month
going around and saying listen all I
want is this little pittance Democrats
won't give it to me let's just make sure
that we're secure if he had spent the
last month really doing an all-out PR
push I think maybe the math is a little
bit different maybe it isn't but things
are certainly getting ugly quickly
according to bloomberg a speedy
conventional wisdom is taking hold that
the LaGuardia Airport closing in New
York will precipitate the end of the
stalemate in Washington indeed security
delays for air travelers are the
shutdowns only real life effect on many
Americans because earlier today the FAA
announced that they were going to shut
down all air traffic in and out of
LaGuardia Airport which is a major
airport obviously one question
as how this may affect the
Transportation Security Administration's
reputation and bargaining position on
budget potential personnel cuts and the
like we're starting to see a revival of
the term security theater the idea that
the TSA which in a 2015 internal
investigation failed to detect 95% of
mock explosives and weapons merely gives
travelers a feeling of security without
actually providing it
that of course is largely true I think
the TSA is a dumb organization overall
that doesn't mean it TSA agents are bad
or that they're bad at their jobs it
just means that you didn't need the TSA
in the first place if we privatize
security at the airports and dealt
Olbers were responsible for security on
Delta flights you'd be better off at
least there would be legal liability
lying with those companies the TSA says
more employees aren't reporting
financial limitations and that is
preventing them from coming into work
the Atlanta Airport is experiencing the
longest average wait time of 42 minutes
the national average is about 30 minutes
right now the FAA says in a statement
there's been a slight increase in sick
leave at two air traffic control
facilities affecting New York as well as
Florida the FAA is adjusting operations
to a safe rate to match available
controller resources so as I say
LaGuardia new the newest information is
that LaGuardia flights have all been
halted as the shutdown hits air-traffic
staffing and there are major delays in
Philadelphia as well as Newark so delays
are gonna start hitting the country it's
all it's all located in the East
basically so we will see how all of this
how all this happens people are getting
optimistic that the shutdown is gonna
end which is why stocks are going up
stocks this morning have been up because
people think that the shutdown is going
to end in the very near future there are
a couple of different proposals on the
table for ending the shutdown President
Trump suggested yesterday that he might
declare a national emergency and then
just fund the wall himself again two
questions would be one if this is true I
didn't just do it earlier right we did
we have to go through five weeks of this
and number two is this really gonna hold
are the courts really gonna uphold his
ability to declare a national emergency
and then redirect funds to build the
wall dicy here's what Trump had to say
about it yesterday and I'll use those
alternatives if I have to we want to go
through the system we have to have a
wall in this country all right so
there's the president suggesting that he
is go
to do something else in order to end the
shutdown I think that's probably how
this ends up going I think the court
probably ends up striking it down I
think the wall doesn't get built that
way but we will find out one of the big
problems here is that Republicans suck
at PR as I've said before if the
Republicans had made a full-court press
not not Republican commentators the
Republicans themselves if Trump had made
a full-court press
if senators had been out there every day
on the campaign trail beating the drums
for why aren't Democrats just giving us
this money this is not that hard if that
had happened it would have it would have
been very helpful instead you've got
idiots like Wilbur Ross the Commerce
Secretary appearing on national
television and saying that everybody is
basically well what's the matter are
people really going hungry Oh Wilbur
Ross Oh Wilbur Ross apparently Wilbur
Ross is so disliked inside the White
House he shuffles around I kid you not
wearing slippers in the White House with
the Commerce Department seal like actual
slippers and he speaks incoherently in
meetings was the rumor hears Wilbur Ross
speaking incoherently on national
television there reports that there are
some federal workers who are going to
homeless shelters to get food well I
know they are and I don't really quite
understand why the obligations that they
would undertake say a borrowing from the
bank or a credit union are in effect
federally guaranteed so the 30 days of
pay that some people will be out there's
no real reason why they shouldn't be
able to get a loan against it okay so
all right Wilbur Ross thank you so much
for your economic insight and then there
a couple of made a boo-boo
he then went on he was on c-span and he
suggested that the reason that
volunteers that people are showing up to
work is not because they want their back
pay it's because they're personally
loyal to Trump which is doubtful at best
with respect to people who do have
financial hardships as some was asking
they are coming to work and giving them
22 same 24/7 work they always did they
on earth and they do it because of their
love for the country and the office of
the presidency and presumably their
allegiance to President Trump but
whatever they're doing it give him some
credit you know there's a lot of
wonderful people
in this country okay they're not doing
it out of allegiance to President Trump
they're doing it because if they leave
their job they won't get paid when the
back pay comes in I mean that's the
reason why you go to work so all sorts
of fun happening over with the Trump
administration this thing is gonna come
to a pretty speedy end at this point
people are annoyed there's no upside the
only question is is what Trump gets in
return if anything at this point okay in
a second I want to discuss the media and
and religion because the media have
continued their attack on religion this
week not just Covington high but an
incredible tweet from a reporter over at
the New York Times we'll get to that in
just one second first you're gonna have
to go over go over to Daily wire and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription to daily wire that comes
along with the rest of this show live it
get to be part of the mailbag which we
are doing today you will also get to see
our live to our show later today every
day we do live two hours of a radio show
and during the breaks we sometimes
answer your question so you should
subscribe just for that we have all
sorts of goodies you should you should
subscribe at YouTube and iTunes as well
because that way you get our Sundays
special our Sundays special this week is
going to be awesome so go check that out
is what we just have all sorts of good
stuff for you at all times it's amazing
all you need to do is subscribe for $99
a year you get all of those wondrous
glories Plus this the very greatest in
all beverage vessels you see it look at
it this it will make your life better go
get it $99 a year go check that out
right now
also make sure you subscribe at YouTube
and iTunes leave us a review we always
appreciate we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in America
[Music]
all righty so I do want to comment on
the continuing media attacks on
religious people there was an
astonishing astonishing tweet yesterday
for a guy named Dan Levin dan Levin says
he covers young America and the issues
they care about for the New York Times
here is what he tweeted yesterday quote
I'm a New York Times reporter writing
about hashtag exposed Christian schools
are you and your 20s are younger who
went to a Christian school I'd like to
hear about your experience and its
impact on your life
please DM me so basically this was him
trolling for a bunch of people who
didn't like the religious school they
went to steak and wine so he can write a
piece about how bad Christian schools
are all of this is on the heels of Karen
pence going back to teach at a Christian
school last week and Covington Catholic
boys going to the March for Life this
week right all of this is designed to
take down Christian schools this is the
next agenda of the mainstream media it's
funny if you wait for about five minutes
the media usually make their agenda
pretty clear when it came to Karen pence
and Cummings in Catholic the agenda was
not Karen pence or the boys of Covington
Catholic the agenda was that religious
schools are inherently deeply terrible
but they are repressive they're
oppressive they're mean to people and
you saw the media's narrative shift over
the course of the Covington Catholic
story specifically in this direction it
went from here are these evil racist
boys look how racist and evil they are
to well maybe they're not racist and
evil per se but maybe other kids at
those school are racist and evil and
then when they couldn't find evidence of
that it became well maybe other schools
in the diocese are homophobic and then
when that fell apart it turned into well
maybe religious schools in general are
just bad maybe religious schools in
general are the problem the this rage
against religion is going to grow the
secular Left feels that they have
religious people on the retreat and they
specifically feel that because the Trump
administration has been very good on
religious issues and because Trump
himself is unpopular they're going to
have Running Room if Trump were to lose
in 2020 this is really what they are
setting up for prepare yourself if Trump
loses in 2020 if Democrats take back the
Senate there will be a push against
religious people in this country worse
than anything we have seen in the last
several decades it will be brutal it
will be an attempt to get rid of
accreditation for religious schools it
will be an attempt to take away
nonprofits
for churches and synagogues it will be
an attempt to take kids out of homes if
those kids are not supposed to have met
leftist standards of social engineering
that's where all of this is going and
the media are leading the charge in all
of this because a lot of members of the
media are people who probably went to
parochial school and now they are on the
left and they don't like that they went
to parochial school they don't like the
parochial schools and so they are going
to attack religion with alacrity this is
an astonishing tweet hashtag exposed
Christian schools I mean just for a
little history lesson Christian schools
are responsible for the vast majority of
education in the history of the West the
vast majority of great universities were
founded as Christian schools education
itself in the Western sense was a
creation of the Catholic Church
the notion that Christian schools are an
inherent bad and that they must don't
obeah be done away with in favor of what
our garbage public school system that's
the solution it's pretty incredible but
what's gonna happen next is a hardcore
push from the left to get rid of
Christian schools all together because
centralization of government control is
always the agenda now speaking of
centralization of government control
under secular leftist it is amazing to
watch as Democrats come out of the
woodwork to defend nicolas maduro
so Ilhan omar one of the fresh faces of
the democratic party so fresh so face
Ilhan omar so Ilhan omar of minnesota
who is an anti-semite and a terrible
person Ilhan omar tweeted out and i say
when i say she's a terrible person i
mean that in 2016
she recommended early release for people
who are linked to Isis like Ilhan omar
not a great person johann omar tweeted
out with regard to the coup attempt in
venezuela or the deadly did the
attempted to pose Nicolas Maduro the
dictator of Venezuela she tweeted out
quote a us-backed coup in Venezuela is
not a solution to the dire issues they
face first of all let me correct myself
it is not in fact a coup it is a
democratic opposition opposing a
dictator she says Trump's efforts to
install a far-right Opposition will only
incite violence and further destabilize
the region okay a couple of things one
Trump isn't the only one who has
recognized Juan cuido who is the who is
the Guido who is the opposition
president here he's been recognized by
virtually every Western country as well
as nearly every country in South America
also he's not far-right he is wait for
it
a social democrat he's a Democratic
Socialist he calls himself that but he's
head of a party called the popular will
not far right but he'll hon Omar is an
idiot as well as as a moral fool she
says we must supreme us support Mexico
guru Gua and the Vatican's effort to
facilitate a peaceful dialogue so she
takes the short way to the same solution
as Maduro Bernie Sanders takes the long
way and what's amazing to me is how many
people were taken in by this like a lot
of people were taken in by Bernie
standards the statement oh look at look
at Bernie Sanders he said the right
thing but Bernie Sanders comes to
exactly the same conclusion as it huh
Nomar which is not a shock since Bernie
Sanders supported the Sandinistas at the
communists Anthony says in Nicaragua who
completely impoverished and destroyed
their country and so here is here is
Bernie Sanders his statement he popped
open
well look we pop open this pudding and
then I will be in a mood to talk about
Venezuela the Maduro government has
waged a violent crackdown on Venezuela
in civil society violated the
Constitution by dissolving the National
Assembly and was reelected last year in
the nun election many observers said was
fraudulent the economy is a disaster and
millions are migrating so so far
everything he says is true I'll also
note somebody should ask Bernie Sanders
why is the economy a disaster Bernie
what happened in Venezuela to make the
economy a disaster did they try you know
a system of centralized government
control and nationalization of industry
and redistribution of wealth maybe that
could that have something to do with it
then Bernie Sanders continues the United
States should support the rule of law
fair elections and self-determination
for the Venezuelan people we must
condemn the use of violence against
unarmed protesters and the suppression
of dissent again oh this is good all of
this is right but then he gets to the
kicker but whenever there's a but after
you say a bunch of correct stuff any
enemy good his but you must learn the
lessons of the past and not to be in the
business of regime change or supporting
coos as we have in Chile Guatemala
Brazil and the dr the US has a long
history of inappropriately intervening
in Latin American nations we must not go
down that road again he supported the
Sandinistas he literally supported the
Sandinistas and now he's supporting
Nicolas Maduro when you say that we
can't get involved really what you're
saying
leave Maduro in place because the
military in Venezuela is backing up
Maduro things are gonna get very ugly
very quickly we should be we should be
providing whatever covert support is
necessary to see Maduro Alstead that
doesn't mean put American troops on the
ground it means do exactly the same
thing we've been doing with folks in
Ukraine if we have to give deadly
weaponry to people who are opposing
Maduro do it give them what they need to
fight Maduro okay let's get to you know
what let's let's do a little bit of mail
bag since it has been a very long week
Daniel says hey Ben it seems to me that
conservatives are not only willing to
engage in dialog but also seek out
dialog with the mission of winning
people over differently the left seems
to shut down dialogue and not seek to
change people's mind in the same way why
do you think this is the case is there
something fundamental about the nature
of the political spectrum that makes it
so well I think right now there are a
lot of folks on the Left who believe
that free speech is a hierarchical
construct they believe that free speech
itself only benefits people who have
historically been powerful and thus we
need to suppress voices in order so that
other voices may flourish and bloom this
is what Arab air Marcuse called
repressive tolerance he suggested that
what we actually needs to repress
certain voices so tolerance can spring
forth in all of its glory this is what
you hear on college campuses when people
say white privilege what they mean you
shut up whitey let everybody else talk
and this is the case that they are
making now they're not wrong then that
in historical terms white people have
had more ability to talk than non-white
people they are wrong that because
history was bad we should make hit we
should make the present bad as well by
shutting people up Randall says hi Ben I
keep hearing from leftist that while AO
sees medicare-for-all plan is expensive
32 trillion dollars plus over 10 years
it would actually be cheaper than the
current projected healthcare expenses
over that same period is this even
possible without severely degrading the
current level of health services Thanks
so the answer is no it means destroying
the entire healthcare industry number
two it'll be a lot more expensive than
32 trillion dollars over 10 plus years
trying to simply trade in private
spending for public spending is not
equivalent private spending is voluntary
spending what you choose to spend on
your medical care versus what the
government is going to spend on your
medical care is not the same number when
they say it will cost 32 trillion over
ten years they mean in public
expenditures you are still going to be
buying supplemental health insurance so
it's just a lie it's not true they if I
don't mistake I believe I think I don't
want to get this wrong I believe
the estimate if you include private
spending would be something like 47
trillion dollars over ten years randy
says may I get a list of the top two or
three sites you use for your facts and
stats on the four to five issues of
importance thank you well you know I do
like to check stats from all sides i the
the bureau of government statistics is
pretty good the Commerce Department has
statistics the FBI has statistics
government stats are generally not
argued with as much as other people
stats but you know I will check a
variety of different outlets so I'll
check Center for American Progress
statistics and Heritage Foundation
statistics
I will check statistics from the
American Enterprise Institute and I will
check City I will check statistics from
the Brookings Institute so try to try to
get a wide variety if you can Conner
says what is the Jewish read on the
third commandment about not taking God's
name in vain so in in halakha and in
Jewish law you're not supposed to use
God's name when you're not making a
broccoli you're not making a blessing
because the idea is that you are
degrading his name but on a conceptual
level I like Dennis preggers take on
this Dennis Prager take on this is that
if you say that God is in favor of
something that God has not himself said
he is in favor of then you are taking
his name in vain
you're perverting what he wants and
making it your own and that's that's a
real act of deep evil let's say Renata
says hey hey Lord been interesting I'm
writing to you because in one of my
classes one of my fellow students
brought up how the Nordic countries have
all these social welfare programs and
how much better they are so I felt the
need to speak up and brought up the
issue that people making over 60k are
taxed about 50 percent depending on
which country you are in their response
was who cares you don't need that much
anyway when the government is taking
care of X on top of that the professor
then stepped in and said obviously
they're doing something right there
since they're consistently ranked as
some of the happiest countries in the
world so my question to you is how would
you have responded to that situation not
gonna lie I folded a little under
pressure since it seemed like it was me
versus the whole class well it's very
hard when everybody's attacking you but
here's the reality in order for them to
determine whether it is in fact
socialism that has made these countries
happy you would have to look at their
happiness ratings and their social
standing before these countries had
piled a bunch of socialist welfare
programs on top of a capitalist base so
look back to the 40s and 50s and 60s and
it turns out these countries were
already some of the happiest on earth it
turns out that the Nordic countries
already had great health care that the
Nordic countries already had a good
economy that they had all of these
things before you started tacking on top
third way Nordic socialism
and there's a great book called what now
imma never forget the name of the book
I've recommended it on the on the
program before i bum king utopia is the
name of the book and it was written by a
guy who is from norway and he let me i'm
gonna look up the name of it NEMA sent
on town she that's his name
I recommend it on the show before he
talked about all of these myths it's
called exposing the myth of Nordic
socialism well worth the read
he talked specifically about the fact
that prior to the advent of all of these
social welfare programs everything was
going pretty well in these places before
they already had high levels of social
cohesion bottom line is this when you
have a society where there are very high
levels of social cohesion virtually any
system will work well for a time for a
time but only for a time meaning that
they've only been trying this for a
couple of decades
it actually has tamp down economic
growth in a large number of these
countries and remember if the United
States were to destroy its own economy
on the shoals of redistribution ISM
there's not gonna be a lot of foreign
investment into the United States if we
change our economic system to make it
less friendly to business there's not
gonna be a lot of entrepreneurial ISM
there's not gonna be a lot of growth
everybody likes to talk about how health
care in other countries is so great who
do you think pays for the developments
of all the medical devices and drugs
like a huge number of the patents the
majority of patents on planet Earth are
coming from the United States in the
healthcare system we pay a premium for
that but it's also why most of these big
healthcare companies are based in the
United States healthcare without without
American customers paying high prices
for services in the private sector
health care would not have developed in
the way that it has everybody else is
living off the cream of the land the
United States is doing the hard work so
socialists say okay why don't we do that
- well then because there is nobody to
support the base upon which this
socialist pile of garbage stands at the
top when Lila says my husband and I have
two children approaching school-age
we're debating private school but our
local private school is extremely
expensive we would be able to afford it
but just barely
how important do you think keeping your
children out of the public school system
is well it depends on the public school
system so some local public schools are
still quite good like when I was growing
up I went to the Burbank Unified School
District very good school district I
went to Edison Elementary School it was
great and then when I was a teenager I
went to Walter Reed junior high not as
good okay so it really depends on the
heist
and the local school but if you have a
bad public school in a great private
school you got to do what you gotta do
to get your kid a solid education and
protect them from the predations of a
bad system okay couple more questions
here let's see Brad says hi Ben I'm
working I'm a working married father of
one soon to be two kids I'd like to have
more children but is it wrong with me to
be pessimistic about the future
considering the left's agenda of
abortion socialism anti religion etc no
I mean I've said that I tend to be a
pessimist because the nice thing about
being a pessimist is you're always right
eventually but that is not a good reason
not to have kids I mean kids are one of
the reasons that you should be
optimistic about the world because who's
gonna fight for the right stuff if you
don't have the kids Cardin says hey Ben
huge fan just subscribed last week
easily the best 99 bucks spent this year
well done Cardin my question is why do
you think all these Hollywood
celebrities are becoming way more
political Kathy Griffin and Alyssa
Milano while politicians are becoming
more like celebrities aoc thanks for all
you do well I think that the people in
Hollywood understand that in the end
what they are doing every day is not
deeply important and so what they want
to do is involve themselves in the
important stuff the really important
stuff and that really important stuff is
politics you have to understand that for
folks in Hollywood everybody has their
celebrities we have our Hollywood
celebrities our Hollywood celebrities
have political celebrities Barack Obama
was a political celebrity for people in
Hollywood and so all these people want
to be associated with important causes
and the way they get involved with these
important causes is by speaking out
politically and becoming famous for
speaking out idiotic ly politically
politicians are becoming more like
celebrities because of TV because we
have short attention spans because the
best way to get attention is to act more
like a celebrity like a OC
than like a politician like Nancy Pelosi
for example when I took Nancy Pelosi
decades to get to this point in
prominence it took al see five seconds
Griffin says dear Ben after a long week
of news I want to ask you a baseball
question yes excellent since you are a
fan of America's pastime what were your
thoughts on the new inductees in the
2019 Hall of Fame vote do you think
Mariano Rivera deserved being the first
unanimous inductee or are there any past
players that should have been given the
nod okay so let start with that one then
we'll get to the next baseball question
so Mariano Rivera is the greatest
reliever in the history of baseball
should've been a unanimous inductee no
if I had known if I'd been a baseball
writer I would have voted against him
specifically so he would not be
unanimous because I believe that the
person with the highest percentage
before that aside from I think Ruth and
Cobb would have been Tom Seaver the idea
that the Mariano Rivera if you're
identifying percentage of the vote with
best baseball player of all time then no
of course he shouldn't get a hundred
percent of the vote he should be in the
Hall of Fame but no reliever should be
receiving a hundred percent of the vote
again his wins over replacement not as
high as I would say many of the starters
in the Hall of Fame maybe the majority
of starters in the Hall of Fame okay
let's see also do you think Barry Bonds
and Roger Clemens will make in the Hall
yes I think Clemens and bonds will both
make it I think the reason they will
eventually make it is because they had
stellar careers before they took
steroids you know that's the difference
in them and for example Jose Canseco who
is taking steroids the entire time bonds
only started taking steroids after he'd
already been I think twice NL MVP and
Roger Clemens only started taking
steroids after he'd already been a
couple times sai yeung Award winner and
the most dominant pitcher of his
generation
I think Forrest says you got Bernie
Trump Obama beta why don't you have an
AOC voice yet it's harder to do female
voices I mean because I'm a biological
male I know shocker the the only female
voice that I do regularly is Nancy
Pelosi and Nancy Pelosi is more just
kind of shifting around her dentures
it's Nancy Pelosi so that really is the
extent of the female voices I do if you
were gonna do an AOC voice it would
really be more in effect try to be more
like the world is an unfair place it's
just like it's unfair and we all know
it's unfair it's that's great it's not
great I need I need to I need to work on
it but I'm not sure it's worthwhile
working on it because she's self
piratical and again SNL already did her
right she was the girl that you wish you
hadn't gotten into a conversation with
over Christmas all right let's see Cole
says dear Ben I'm not sure which Marvel
films you haven't haven't seen what are
your thoughts on Captain America the
Winter Soldier it's often regarded as
the best Marvel film by hardcore fans I
think the theme is present throughout
make it more than your standard
superhero movie I got to say I'm not a
Captain America fan in the movies not
just because Chris Evans said on Twitter
that he dislikes me but also because I
just think that he's a block of wood I
just don't think he's a very good actor
I mean you put him on the same screen as
Robert Downey jr. and no one wants to
watch Chris Evans now I remember
watching the Winter Soldier I don't
remember I
honestly do not remember five minutes of
that movie this is my problem the Marvel
movies in general I think Marvel is best
when they're liked like door Ragnarok
and yes ant-man like honestly I think I
think that's where they're best
I think Marvel is weakest when they try
to take on serious themes I think DC is
best when they take on serious themes
like The Dark Knight I think they're
weakest when they attempt to do the
jokey jokey stuff because they can't do
it as well as Marvel alright one more
question in then we're done Blake says
hi Ben my brother and I disagree on
everything about except about everything
except Ohio State football I'm pretty
conservative he's very liberal I
recently told him the government
shutdown doesn't bother me much because
it shows the checks the branches have on
each other
he counter argued that with that Trump
is abusing his power by using people's
paycheck as a bargaining chip
our shutdowns part of the checks and
balances or is an abuse of power on
either side whether it be the President
or Congress know it's part of the checks
and balances of power it's gonna be fine
ask your brother whether he felt the
same way when Obama was refusing to sign
a bill like the president doesn't have
an obligation to sign a funding bill he
doesn't so yes it's just part of the
checks and balances Congress has given
the power of the purse strings and the
president has the power to veto alrighty
so let's do a couple of things I like
and then we'll do a thing I hate so
things that I like today my friend Steve
days over at conservative Review has a
book out called truth bombs it's worth
picking up Steve's an interesting writer
with an interesting perspective and it's
it's a good read I mean I've read the
book so go pick that up truth bomb now
sixes you know it's been a long let's
let's hate some stuff let's just go to
things I hate no hatred of religion has
become very trendy these days I love
that Richard Dawkins who is not world's
greatest human Richard Dawkins tweeted
out this yesterday contemplation of
World War one and two persuades me that
patriotism my country right or wrong
might be even more evil than
supernatural faith Italians in 1943
deserve credit for finally turning on
their preposterous do che
but for Germans the lure of patriotic
loyalty was too strong okay a couple
things a couple of key factors in the
defeat of the Nazis as well as communism
patriotism and supernatural faith eight
people in World War two fighting on
behalf of the United States were
Patriots people fighting on behalf of
the Soviet Union which helped defeat the
Nazis were Patriots belief in God was a
key component to
the West's fight against both Soviet
communism and Nazism it was it was the
Pope visiting Poland that helped to
increase the labor movement in Poland
helping to lead to the decline of the
Soviet Union so Richard Dawkins knows
less about history than he does about
the Bible one of the great points of
irritation for me is that you know I
actually spend time trying to read as
much about science as I can as much
about neurobiology as I can you know try
it trying to read about topics that
people like Richard Dawkins like to talk
about I like to read about evolution I
find it interesting Richard Dawkins
spent two minutes with a Gideon Bible
and thinks that he is now an expert on
religion it's highly irritating like I
look now at Richard Dawkins knows way
more about biology than I do but he
knows less than my daughter does about
religion and then he had to apologize he
says sorry for failing to say those who
bravely fought for the Allies in World
War two may have been patriotic but
unlike axis soldiers no need for my
country right or wrong their country was
right they were fighting Hitler I joined
them but not for reasons of patriotism
and not World War one okay well I mean
if we're going to define patriotism as
my country right or wrong then of course
no one of good faith is in favor of that
because if your country is slaughtering
people on mass for no reason then you'd
probably not want to be in favor of your
country doing that but I love that he's
able to separate out patriotism for the
United States and patriotism for Germany
for purposes of declaring it patriotism
if you want to say nationalism that's a
more accurate description about
patriotism that's foolishness and of
course his arguments about religion are
just full-scale stupid and it's just not
even close to reality okay what let's
see one more quick thing so I I'm not
sure I wasn't sure whether to put this
in things I like her things I hate to
mark Lamont Hill who you'll remember
went to the UN and called from the river
to the sea Palestine should be free the
destruction of the State of Israel mark
Lamont Hill was on a radio show recently
and he let it slip that a bunch of
Democrats agree with him which of course
we knew if I had a dollar for every
progressive member of Congress for every
progressive faculty member for every
progressive cable news or otherwise TV
commentator who sent me a private
message saying I agree with you can
almost hear the whispers in the mess I
agree with you but you know stay strong
but this is why I don't say anything I
wouldn't need a TV job I'd have so much
money I mean it's
it's actually stunning to see how people
have responded I am sure this is 100%
true I'm sure this is a hundred percent
true and that there are lots of
Democrats and members of the media who
have expressed their have expressed
their support for Mark Lamont Hill and
who won't come out and say it publicly I
think everyone should come out and say
if they agree with Mark Lamont Hill so
we can determine whether to take you
seriously as a human or not okay final
thing that I hate is more so away the
Superbowl is gonna have male
cheerleaders I don't believe that this
is gonna be like the cool kind of male
cheerleaders who throw the ladies up in
the air at the college football games I
believe that it's just a bunch of men
who are dancing alongside the women
now let's yeah that's what it is I guess
they're they are going to dance with
women performing all the same moves the
the people's names are Peron and Janis
that's the name of Quintin Peron and
Napoleon Ginny's who are going to be
part of the cheerleading squad
one of them said that it's like a fairy
tale adding it's been a crazy ten months
dancing hard really engaging with our
community our team and supporting our
players I can't believe that we made it
to this point
I'm pretty sure it's showing off that
we've been working so hard okay let me
just Express how dumb this is it is true
leading sexist is it a bunch of men ugly
women of course it is okay we're gonna
pretend that it's not that is of course
what it is naturally like yes now am I
in favor of cheerleading as a general
rule know if we're gonna pretend now
that cheerleading is all about the
beauty of dance and we're gonna have
them to like modern art pieces or
something alright but that's not what
this is okay and pretend that women are
viewing male cheerleaders the same way
men view female cheerleaders is simply
selling let's just acknowledge what
cheerleading is for what it is I'm all
in favor of ending it if it really is
just kind of a dumb down strip club
routine but if it's an actual you know
gymnastic routine that's a cool thing
but then let guys do what guys do which
is lift heavy objects in this case
namely women and throw them high into
the air I love this idea that what it's
really about is the art of the dance
yeah sure sure you tell yourself that
guys you tell yourself that NFL it was
never sexist of course it was sexist can
we just like tell truths here apparently
not cheerleading was all about respect
for the bodies of women mm-hmm this is
why again I was never this is why I like
baseball no cheerleaders in baseball
alrighty so we will be back here a
little bit later today this is why
should subscribe we have two hours later
today I'm sure there will be lots of
updates I'm Roger stone and the FAA
a and all the rest so be there or be
square I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam sy events
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wired production
copyright daily wire 20 19